[Musique]
merci Charlie lescolin d'accueil à
notera donc l'atelier est-ce que c'est
un besoin pour de pain tous les jours
oui c'est une raison de vivre les doigts
aujourd'hui que ça ou peine vraiment
d'avoir les outils aujourd'hui pour
commencer les marrons c'est ce que mes
maths avaient diamants en Asie là-bas
j'ai ma séance et 60 ans que m'a fait la
plus grosse part de mon travail et à 54
ans maintenant les outils
on a des épisodes ou à part tout de
suite alors qu'avant il faisait un
tableau c'était un tableau
[Musique]
et comment définirait l'influence de
l'Asie sur le travail
des joncs et des reflets d'eau des
reflets sur l'eau c'était dans les
restos chinois donc comme méthode
travail bien l'école papa
vu mes tableaux avec les montagnes pris
dans la dans les nuages etc mais pense
que c'est celle là du Cap le lame du
t-shirt il à l'époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça que le chemin finalement
la diriger vers l'Asie ou exporte au
travail vers l'Asie
il a eu la Chine la Corée du Sud la
partie Calcutta fait les Philippines et
à chaque fois mais de monnaie Parlement
il parle avec moi comme si de d'autres
pays mais
la trace des ancêtres parce qu'on a
beaucoup des ancêtres qui sont pas réac
en Afrique ou en Madagascar on a
beaucoup de recettes qui sont en Asie
les Indonésiens les Malaisiens la racine
mais la petite ici en tant qu'esclave
donc quelque part tout ça c'est pas très
loin
[Musique]
on peut dire qu'on a une certaine
reconnaissance ou là d'ailleurs décroché
un Award en Corée du Sud et plein de
diplômes à droite à gauche dans les pays
à droite à gauche et c'est ma grande
fierté parce que mon ami a qu'un cap m'a
pas fait les Beaux-Arts ni rien et voilà
tu es pour moi ta maman que voilà avec
le travail il gagne il arrive à quelque
chose
[Musique]
aujourd'hui que vous voulez le chef de
fil la rue
c'est un travail chouette parce que il
pousse ses antices à faire des autres CV
en revois d'autres CV actualiser faire
en anglais des fois même en taille dans
des Wan chinois après parasol il pousse
aux attaquants anglais parce qu'il faut
il faut les traits professionnels en
fait
à nous la question où ça il vient tout
cette énergie de Charlie lescolin a
toujours avancé toujours positiver et
toujours porté plus haut quoi je pense
que c'est la France La Réunion je pense
que c'est la force à la Réunion c'est
des fois nous doutes mais si nous prend
l'âme notre pays et nous mettre dans nos
cœurs nous nous tiennent qui tient à
Beaufort pour tenir
c'est un travail compta maladie contre
le l'ennui etc mais il faut travailler
il faut travailler voilà ça c'est
satisfait réussi à ce travail tous les
jours
merci beaucoup Charlie c'est un plaisir
[Musique]